[Music]
it didn't look a lot like christmas this
year in bethlehem
celebrations were restricted to the bare
minimum
as coveted 19 cases surge
[Music]
only few worshipers were allowed to
attend the midnight mass in the church
of the nativity
the pandemic with with its burden of
suffering and death
asks us to imagine a different world
made up of new solidarity and fraternal
relationships
where possessing is replaced by
giving and the wealth of
a few becomes a benefit for everyone
the palestinian president and many
foreign diplomats
didn't join the christmas service
the day started with a low-key reception
of the latin patriarch of jerusalem
a procession to welcome him usually
attracts thousands
this year he gave his blessings from a
distance
you can feel the town's sadness this is
not how christmas looks
it's also the first time that we didn't
attend the christmas tree lightning
ceremony
palestine's first cases of copper 19
were reported in bethlehem in march
tourism dried up in a country that
heavily depends on it
the tourism ministry says that losses
this year
are estimated at one and a half billion
dollars
rafa chomeli makes a living out of
tourism he arranges community-based tour
guides
and says 2019 was a very good season
now he expects his business to pick up
in october
of next year we had fully booked maybe a
year in advance
it was the first time maybe we had this
since the birth of jesus you know
so it was amazing we were expecting an
amazing year and
things have changed but it's going to be
back
i pray
almost all christmas related festivities
were called off
instead pre-recorded christmas carols
were broadcasted online
the palestinian authority says it tried
to limit gatherings as much as possible
to combat the spread of the coronavirus
this year
there are fewer christmas lights and
decorations than usual
but some here tell us that the message
of christmas is
all about hope and they're praying that
next year
will be better ibrahim
the occupied west bank